UPCOMING MEETING WITH KIM
JONG-UN.
GLAD YOU ARE WITH US, TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
HUGE DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY, RUDY
GUILIANI WILL JOIN US.
HE IS TELLING THE NEW YORK TIMES
THAT SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER IS AGREEING TO LIMIT THE
SCOPE OF THE QUESTIONS AND THE
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR IS SAYING IT
COULD RESULT IN A POSSIBLE JULY
INTERVIEW AND MUELLER ISSUING
A FINAL REPORT BY LABOR DAY AND
THE MID- TERM ELECTION.
THAT WOULD BE A WIN FOR THE
PRESIDENTS.
MUELLER'S ORIGINAL QUESTIONS
WERE RIDICULOUS AND A PERJURY
TRAP AND WHAT WERE YOU THINKING.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT HE WAS
THINKING AND TODAY IS THE ONE
YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE MUELLER
WITCH HUNT.
AND SO FAR THERE IS NOT A SINGLE
SHRED OF EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
AND THAT IS NOT AGAINST THE LAW.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS SO
ABUSIVE AND CORRUPT AND SO
CONFLICTED THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS LEGAL TEAM ARE RIGHTLY
GOING TO OFFENSE TO SOLICIT THE
DEEP STATE TEAM.
CONGRATULATIONS, THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED.
WE ARE IN THE SECOND YEAR OF THE
GREATEST WITCH HUNT IN HISTORY
AND NO COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION.
ONLY COLLUSION IS DONE BY THE
DEMOCRATS WHO WERE UNABLE TO WIN
THE ELECTION DESPITE THE
SPENDING OF FAR MORE MONEY.
>> ALL MULLER IS TRYING TO DO IS
TO GET PAUL MANAFORT TO FLIP AND
BRINGING UP TAX CHARGES FROM
2005 AND 7 AND IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
LOOK AT MUELLER'S EMBARRASSING
CASE AGAINST THE RUSSIAN BOUGHT
COMPANIES.
THAT IS FALLING APART.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE WITH ALL OF
THESE GREAT ATTORNEYS LIKE
ANDREW WEISSMAN HE INDICTED
A COMPANY THAT DIDN'T EXIST AT
THE TIME.
AND HE TOLD CONGRESS THAT HE
DIDN'T THINK MICHAEL FLYNN.
THERE IS SOMETHING OFF WITH WHAT
IS HAPPENING TO GENERAL FLYNN.
IT IS A ABUSE OF POWER AND
UNLIKE ANYTHING THE COUNTRY HAS
BEEN SEEING AND THE MEDIA IS
MIA.
IT IS COSTING THE AMERICAN TAX
WARDS UPWARDS OF $10 MILLION.
AND BECAUSE OF ALL OF THESE
FACTS, THE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL
TEAM IS NO LONGER SITTING BACK
AND WATCHING MUELLER AND THE
DEEP STATE OPERATIVES AND
WATCHING IT UNFOLD.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS NO LONGER
CONSIDERING TO INDICTING THE
PRESIDENT.
& ALTHOUGH IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
THERE IS NO CONSTITUTIONAL
PRECEDENT TO EVEN CONSIDER THIS.
THEY ARE LONG ESTABLISHED DOJ
GUIDELINE AND WE EXPLAINED THOSE
IN PLACE.
AND FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR
RUDY GUILIANI POINTED OUT THAT
MUELLER MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ISSUE
A SUPPENA BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM HANDED
OVER A MILLION DOCUMENTS AND
MUELLER HAS EVERYTHING
REQUESTED.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO HAVE A.
AND THAT IS A DIRECT THREAT TO
THE AMERICAN REPUBLIC.
MUELLER IS CALLING DAMAGE TO AT
THIS TIME RULE OF LAW IN THIS
COUNTRY AND THE NEW YORK TIMES
CONFIRMING ALL OF THE REPORTING
THAT WE HAD OVER THE YEAR AND
PART OF IT IS THE OBAMA FBI DID
IN FACT HAVE A MOLE INSIDE OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
DON'T THINK FOR A SECOND THAT
THE NEW YORK TIMES DIDN'T DO IT
ON PURPOSE.
THEY SUDDENLY DECIDED TO TELL
THE TRUTH FOR ONCE?
THIS WAS NOT A SIMPLE
AND THE ONLY REASON TO BURY THE
LEAD OF THE STORY AND TRYING TO
SPIN AND COVER UP FOR THOSE
PEOPLE THAT THEY WOULD NOT COVER
FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR, THOSE WHO
ARE INVOLVED IN ALL OF THE
ILLICIT ACTIVITY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW, THE DEEP
STATE KNOWS THEY ARE ABOUT TO
EXPOSE.
WE ARE EXPECTING THE IG REPORT
AND WE'LL SEE THE 1.2 MILLION
DOCUMENTS THAT THE IG LOOKED AT.
AND IT IS OBVIOUS AND
TRANSPARENT.
THEY ARE LEAKING INFORMATION TO
GET OUT IN FRONT OF THE
AND THAT IS STORMY, STORMY.
AND THE DOJ IS TRYING TO LEAK
THE INFORMATION TO FRIENDLY
MEDIA.   THE NEW YORK TIMES IS
NO ONE FRIENDLIER.
AND REMEMBER THEY BROKE THE
STORY THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
GET AHEAD OF DEVIN NUNNES.
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT
SOUND OFF.
WE KNEW ABOUT THIS.
REMEMBER CONGRESS HASN'T BEEN
ABLE TO SEE THE INFORMATION,
WHY?
AND THAT IS RIGHTLY.
AND THAT IS THE NEW YORK TIMES
REPORT.
AND THE FBI OBTAINED AND THE
SECRET TYPE OF SUBPEONA.
AND AT LEAST ONE GOVERNMENT
INFORMANT MET WITH CARTER PAGE.
AND SO WE HAVE A SECRET TYPE OF
SUBPEONA AND THE OBAMA USED TO
SPY ON THE CAMPAIGN.
AND IT IS IN THREE SUBSEQUENT
APPLICATION AND DOSZIER PUT
TOGETHER BY A FOREIGN NATIONAL
TO GET A WARRANT AND TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
YOU ARE KEEPING UP WITH ME HERE?
THIS IS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THE TOP PEOPLE.
DOY, AND FBI AND NOT RACHG AND
FILE MAKING SURE THEY HAD EVERY
BASE OF THEIRS COVERED BECAUSE
THEIR GOAL WAS TO GET TRUMP BY
ANY MEANS NECESSARY AFTER THEY
HELPED HILLARY RIG THE
INVESTIGATION.
EXXONERATION BEFORE
AND FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR,
RUDY GUILIANI, SAID THIS COULD
BLOW UP THE ENTIRE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
>> IN THIS CASE, WE'LL HAVE TO
CHALLENGE THE LEJETIMACY OF THE
ENTIRE INVESTIGATION.
MAYBE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR OR
COUNSEL SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED.
AND NOT BASED ON A SET OF THE
FACTS THAT GO BACK TO.
I AM SHOCKED TO HEAR THEY PUT
A SPY IN THE CAMPAIGN OF A MAJOR
PARTY CANDIDATE OR MAYBE TWO
SPIES AND NOW, YOU KNOW, I WAS
A PART OF THAT CAMPAIGN AND I AM
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO WAS THE
SPY.
IS IT THIS PURPOSE OR THAT
PERSON.
IF IT IS A SPY, THEY GOT NOTHING
FROM IT.
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO BRING THE
CASE RIGHT NOW IF THEY HAD
INCRIMINATING INFORMATION.
>> Sean: HERE IS ANOTHER PIECE
OF INFORMATION FROM THE NEW YORK
TIMES ARTICLE.
AND HAVE DAYS AFTER THEY CLOSED
THE INVESTIGATION AND THE
ILLEGAL USE OF THE PRIVATE
E-MAIL SERVER AND THE ONES THAT
HELP
HEL
HELPED TO EXANERATE HILLARY.
AND THAI THEN THEY SCRUTINIZED
THE CAMPAIGN OF HER REPUBLICAN
RIVAL.
THEY PUT THE FIX IN AND
EXONERATED HILLARY CLINTON AND
WE KNOW SHE COMMITTED FELONY.
AND WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
AND DAYS LATER, THEY WENT AFTER
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY THOUGHT THEY KNEW BETTER
THAN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT MEANS YOU.
AND IF ALL OF THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH.
THERE IS SEVERS IMPLICATIONS AND
TOP AUSTRALIAN OFFICIAL AND THEY
BROKE WITH PROTOCOL AND ALLOWED
THE AMBASSADOR TO SIT FOR A FBI
INTERVIEW TO DESCRIBE HIS
INTERVIEW WITH GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
AND THAT MEANS OBAMA HAD TO KNOW
FROM DAY ONE.
AND THAT MEANS THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE HAD TO SIGN OFF ON IT FROM
DAY ONE.
NO ONE ELSE IN THE MEDIA IS
REPORTING THIS.
THERE GOES WAY BEYOND COMEY AND
TOP LEVEL FBI AND DOJ DEEP STATE
AGITATORS.
OBAMA AND JOHN KERRY NEED TO
EXPLAIN WHAT THEY KNOW AND WHEN
DID THEY KNOW IT?
THERE IS NO WAY THAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED WITHOUT THEIR APPROVAL.
AND THE DOJ AND IG REPORT THAT
WE JUST MENTIONED WHEN WE COME
OUT.
AND SARAH CARTER BREAKING NEWS,
A DRAFT OF THE HIGHLY
ANTICIPATED REPORT OF THE
HANDLING OF THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN SENT TO
CONGRESS.
FINALLY 14 OR 15 MONTHS.
IT IS EXTREMELY LONG AND
THOROUGH.
SARAH IS ALSO REPORTING THAT IT
DOES NOT CONTAIN REFERRALS.
THAT WOULD COME IN THE LIKE THE
CASE WAS ANDREW McCABE.
AND COMES WITH ONE SMALL TASK TO
PAY ATTENTION TO.
FOX NEWS REPORTING THAT THE FBI
AND DOJ HAVE IT.
AND THEY ARE ALLOWED TO REVIEW
THE IG'S DRAFT AND THAT MEANS
THEY WILL MAYBE OFFER INSTANCES
TO REDACT INFORMATION AND THAT
MEANS THE DEEP STATE WOULD BE
ABLE TO ATTEMPT TO HIDE THE
TRUTH.
THIS IS WHY ROD ROSENSTEIN AND
THE DOJ'S MO.
THEY STONE WALL AND WHEN THAT
DOESN'T WORK THEY REDACT UNDER
THE NATIONAL GUISE OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE REDAUKT
DAKT SO FAR IS NOT NATIONAL
SECURITY.
BUT EMBARRASSING DETAILS LIKE
JAMES COMEY AND THE FBI DIDN'T
THINK MIKE FLYNN LIED.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THEY ARE
NOT CAPABLE MUCH HOMING
THEMSELVES ACCOUNTABLE AND THE
INSPECTORS GENERAL NEEDS TO HOLD
FIRM ON HIS REPORT TONIGHT.
ROBERT MUELLER TURNED OVER THE
SCOPE MEMO OF HIS INVESTIGATION
TO FEDERAL JUDGE TRNGS S ELLIS
THE THIRD.
AND ANDREW WEISSMAN, HE WENT
AFTER MUELLER'S TEAM.
AND THEY WENT AFTER PAUL
MANAFORT.
2005 ALREADY INVESTIGATED TAX
FRAUD ISSUE THAT HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE ELECTION OR CAMPAIGN
OR RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
THE SAME JUDGE BLASTING THE
MUELLER TEAM TRYING TO GET
MANAFORT TO FLIP.
THEY WANT TO PUT THE SCREWS TO
HIM AND MAKE HIM SING SO THEY
CAN PROSECUTE OR IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND ONE OF THE MOST A GREJOUS
EXAMPLES OF MEDIA BIAS.
THE PRESS CLAIMING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ANIMALS.
IT WAS NOT THE CASE.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT SPECIFIC
MEMBERS OF THE MS13 GAMES.
THEY KNOWINGLY, AND PURPOSELY
TOOK THE PRESIDENT OUT OF
CONTEXT TO TRY TO SMEAR HIM YET
AGAIN.
NEWS MEDIA, JOURNALISM IN
AMERICA IS DEAD.
AND THIS SHAMEFUL MEDIA
COVERAGE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS POSING
AS NEWS IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS TO MEASURE HIS WORLDS
AND BE MORE CAREFUL.
IT IS SLIPPERY SLOPE WHEN YOU
DEHUMANIZE PEOPLE THIS WAY.
IT IS WHAT THE NAZIS DID AND NOT
WHAT AMERICAN INS DO.
>> THE PRESIDENT CALLED PEOPLE
ANIMALS.
>> THAT WAS IN A WHITE HOUSE
MEETING ON SANCTUARY CITIES AND
SOMEONE REMARKED ABOUT MS 13
GANG MEMBERS.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T MAKE IT
CLEAR IF IT IS GANG MEMBERS AND
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES SAY IT IS
DOWN RIGHT DANGEROUS LANGUAGE.
>> Sean: WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY SAY?
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE VICIOUS
GANG KNOWN AS MS 13.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MS 13 GANG MEMBER.
IF THEY DON'T TELL ICE ABOUT
THEM?
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE TRYING TO COME
IN.
WE ARE TAKING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE HOW BAD
THEY ARE.
THEY ARE NOT PEOPLE.
THEY ARE ANIMALS.
AND WE ARE TAKING THEM OUT OF
THE COUNTRY AT A LEVEL AND RATE
THAT NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE WEAK LAWS,
THEY COME IN FAST AND WE GET
THEM AND RELEASE THEM.
AND GET THEM AGAIN.
WE GET THEM OUT AND IT'S CRAZY.
>> Sean: AND THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDED TO THE ABUSIVELY
BIASSED MEDIA.
>> YOU KNOW I AM REFERRING TO
THE MS 13 GANGS THAT ARE COMING
IN AND TALKING ABOUT MS 13.
AND IN THE TAPE YOU WILL SEE
THAT AND I AM SURPRISED YOU
ASKED THIS QUESTION.
AND MOST PEOPLE GOT IT RIGHT.
MS 13.
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT WHERE YOU
COME FROM.
THEY COME IN AND THEY ARE
ANIMALS.
AND SO WHEN MS 13 AND GANG
MEMBERS COME IN I REFER TO THEM
AS ANIMAL AND GUESS WHAT, I
ALWAYS WILL.
>> Sean: MEDIA BIAS IS NOT THE
ONLY THING HE TALKED ABOUT.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT NORTH KOREA.
>> NOTHING HAS CHANGED ON NORTH
KOREA AND IF IT DOES, THAT'S
FINE.
IF IT DOESN'T WE'LL HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL MEETING.
BUT WE HAVE NOT BEEN TOLD
ANYTHING.
WE ARE RADDING STOERP STORES
LIKE YOU ARE AND WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
WE ARE NEGOTIATING IN TERMS OF
LOCATION.
AS TO WHERE AND HOW TO MEET AND
ROOMS AND EVERYTHING ELVES.
AND THEY NEGOTIATED LIKE NOTHING
HAPPENED.